[Musik]
aufgrund der uno-resolution 698 des un
sicherheitsrates wurde im kriegsgebiet
in kuwait eine entmilitarisierte zone
geschaffen
als eine der ersten friedenstruppen
wurde ein kontingent österreichischer
un-truppen in zypern auf die verlegung
vorbereitet bei verlassen der insel
wurden den soldaten die abzeichen der
österreichischen kompanie aus kreuth
überreicht
[Applaus]
neben dem österreichischen kontingent
wurde auch eine dänische kompanie fertig
nach der ankunft am airport kuba cd
wurde die kompanie nach doha verlegt um
katar war der einzige irakische hafen er
liegt im grenzgebiet zu kuwait unweit
der großstadt basra in doha wurde durch
die un-truppen die lok bates errichtet
dieses lager dient in der ersten phase
des friedens einsatzes auch den
österreichern als ausgangspunkt für die
folgenden aufgaben als kommandant der un
truppen in kuwait und im irak wurde der
österreichische general günter brendel
von der uno bestellt in seiner funktion
als force commander nahm die parade der
eingesetzten 600 infanterie soldaten aus
fünf nationen der 300 beobachtungs
offiziere hinter rund 200 versorgung
soldaten ab
hier die drei sektoren und der weg der
österreicher von der lok base ins
headquarter in kasan
[Musik]
die tarot in den letzten kriegstagen
bekämpften hier die alliierten brächte
die zurückziehenden iraker aus der luft
und das ist das resultat
und so bot sich die arabische hafenstadt
und pazar den österreichern da ein
marinestützpunkt der iraker er diente
den österreichern als quartier und wurde
zum hauptquartier für union vorbereitet
nach der entfernung von sprengkörpern
und ihnen begann der aufbau des lagers
[Musik]
um das lager herum und im ganzen bereich
des habens von kazaa lang tonnen von
irakischen kriegs gewinnt
sicherungsaufgaben fahrzeug und
personenkontrolle waren die ersten
aufträge die zu erfüllen war
dieser check point nahe der grenze wurde
unter anderem auf zusicherung der
flüchtlingslager errichtet
das feld spital in katar wurde von einer
norwegischen sanitäts einheit betrieben
versorgt wurde neben den un soldaten
auch die zivilbevölkerung
österreichische soldaten sicherten das
spitals gelände nach dem abzug der
alliierten kräfte aus ihren stellungen
und lagern nahe kurve und dem abzug der
drei infanterie kompanien der un-truppen
übernahm einzug der österreicher den
sektor nord in diesem abschnitt befanden
sich die größten irakischen gaslager die
weitgehend unbeschädigt blieben für die
us-truppen selbstverständlich hamburger
und cola lange schlangen beim px shop
duty free in der wüste
telefonverbindungen mittels satelliten
standen allen soldaten zur verfügung
im versorgungslager konnten die
österreichischen friedenssoldaten für
die kompanie unicom lebensmittel und
diverse sanitätsmaterial übernehmen
[Musik]
die vorhandene infrastruktur wurde durch
geschick konnten den reichtum der
österreicher sofort verbessert und
konnte somit genutzt werden
ständige alarmbereitschaft und exaktes
üben der geplanten ablauf verließen
selten urlaubsstimmung aufkommen
schnelles reagieren auf lage
entwicklungen waren zur erfüllung des
auftrages notwendig
[Musik]
der einsatz der österreichischen
friedensgruppen endete am 17 juni 1991